the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so let's not write away with stuff that
we will need to see before we can go
into more advanced things so hopefully
yesterday in recitation you heard a bit
about vectors how many of you actually
knew about vectors before that okay
that's the vast majority if you are not
one of those people well hopefully you
will learn about vectors right now I'm
sorry that the learning curve will be a
bit steeper for the first week but
hopefully you will adjust fine if you
have you know trouble with vectors do go
to your instructors recitation
instructors of the cells for you know
extra practice if you feel the need to
you see it's pretty easy so just to
remind you a vector is a quantity that
has both a direction and the magnitude
length so
so concretely the way you draw a vector
is by some a hole like that okay and so
it has a length and it's pointing in
some direction and so now the way that
we compute things with vectors typically
is we introduce a coordinate system so
if when the plane XY axis if we're in
space XYZ axis so usually I will try to
draw my XYZ axis consistently to look
like this and then I can represent my
vector in terms of its components along
the coordinate axes so that means when I
have this arrow I can ask how much does
it go in the X direction how much does
it go in the Y direction how much does
it go in the Z direction and so whenever
let's call this vector a so a small
convention when we have a vector
quantity we put an arrow on top to
remind us that it's a vector if it's in
a textbook then sometimes it's in bold
because it's easier to typeset if you've
tried you know in your favorite what
processor does bold is easy and vectors
are not easy so the vector you can try
to decompose in terms of unit vectors
directed along the coordinate axes so
the convention is there's a vector that
we call I had that points along the x
axis and has length one there's a vector
called
J hat that does the same along the y
axis and the K hat that does the same
along the z axis and so we can express
any vector in terms of its components so
the other notation is a1 a2 a3 between
these square brackets well maybe it's
the angular brackets
so the length of a vector will denote by
if you want it's the same notation as
the absolute value so that's going to be
a number as we say now a scalar quantity
okay so a scalar quantity is a usual
numerical quantity as opposed to a
vector quantity and it's Direction
sometimes called there of a and that can
be obtained just by scaling the vector
down to unit length for example by
dividing it by its length so
well there's a lot of notation to be
learned so for example if I have two
points P and Q then I can draw a vector
from P to Q and that vector is called
the graphic you okay so maybe we call it
a but a vector doesn't really have
necessarily a starting point and an
ending point yes if I decide to start
here and I go by the same distance in
the same direction this is also the
vector a it's the same vector so a lot
of vectors will go starting at the
origin but we don't have to so let's
just check and see how things went in
recitation when they put it so let's say
that I give you the vector 3 2 1 and so
what do you think about the length of
this vector
okay I see an answer forming so a lot of
you are answering the same thing maybe I
shouldn't spoil it for those who haven't
yet okay I think the other whelming vote
is in favor of answer number two I see
some sixes I don't know that's a
perfectly good answer to but hopefully
in a few minutes it might be I don't
know anymore so let's see how do we find
the length of a vector three two one
well so this vector a it comes towards
us along the x axis by three units it
goes to the right along the y axis by
two units and then it goes up by one
unit along the z axis okay so it's
pointing towards here let's put it out
to the hall so how do we get its length
well maybe we can start with something
easier the length of a vector in the
plane so observe that you know a is
obtained from the vector B in the plane
B equals three I had plus 2 J hat and
then we just have to still go up by one
unit okay so let me try to draw a
picture in this vertical plane that
contains a and B if I draw it in the
vertical plane so that's the z axis
that's not any particular axis then my
vector B will go here and my vector a
will go above it and here that's one
unit
and here I have a right angle so I can
use the Pythagorean theorem to find that
length a squared equals length B squared
plus one now we are reduced to finding
the length of B but the length of B we
can again find using the Pythagorean
theorem in the XY plane because here we
have the right angle here we have three
units and here we have two units okay so
if you do the calculations you will see
that
well length of B is square root of three
squared plus two squared that's 13 so
square root of 13 and length of a is a
square root of length B squared plus 1
squared if you want which is going to be
square root of 13 plus 1 is square root
of 14
hence and so number 2 which almost all
of you gave ok so the general formula
you know if you follow it with it in
general if we have a vector with
components a 1 a 2 a 3 then the length
of a is the square root of a 1 squared
plus a 2 squared plus a 3 squared ok
any questions about that
yes yes so in general we indeed can
consider vectors in abstract spaces that
have any number of coordinates and then
you have more components in this class
we'll mostly see vectors with two of a
components only because they are easier
to draw and because a lot of the math
that we'll see works exactly the same
way whether you have three variables or
a million variables if we had a vector
with more components then we would have
a lot of trouble drawing it but we could
still define its length in the same way
by summing the squares of the components
so I'm sorry to say that here you know
multi variable multi will mean mostly
two or three but be assured that it
works just the same way if you have
10,000 variables just calculations are
longer okay
more questions okay so what else can we
do with vectors well another thing that
I'm sure you know how to do with vectors
is to add them or to scale them so
vector addition so if you have two
vectors a and B then you can form them
some there's some a plus B how do we do
that well first I should tell you
vectors you know they have this double
life they're at the same time geometric
objects that we can draw like this on
pictures and there are also
computational objects that we can
represent by numbers so every question
about vectors will have two answers one
geometric and one numerical it so let's
start with a geometry so let's say that
I have two vectors a and B given to me
and let's say that I thought of drawing
them at the same place to start with
well to take the sum what I should do is
actually move B so that it starts at the
end of a at the head of a ok so this is
a gain vector B
so observe this actually forms now a
parallelogram right so this side is
again vector E and now if we take the
diagonal of that parallelogram this is
what we call a plus B okay so the idea
being that to move along a plus B it's
the same as to move first along a and
then along beach all along B then along
a a plus B equals B plus a okay now if
we do it numerically then all you do is
you just add the first component of a
with the first component of B the second
with the second and the third with the
filled okay say that a was a 1 a 2 a 3 B
was B 1 B 2 B 3 then you just add this
way okay so it's pretty straightforward
so for example you know I said that my
vector out of there its components are
PHA 2 1 but I also voted as 3 times I
plus 2 times J plus K what does that
mean oh so I need to tell you first
about multiplying by a scalar so this is
about addition so multiplication by a
scalar it's very easy if you have a
vector a then you can form a vector to a
just by making it go twice as far in the
same direction okay or we can make have
a number 3 or we can even make a minus a
and so on so now you see if I do the
calculation three times I plus 2 times J
plus K well what does it mean three
times I is just going to go along the x
axis but by distance of 3 instead of 1
and then 2 times J goes 2 units along
the y axis
and k goes up by one unit well if you
add these together you will go from the
origin then along the x-axis then
parallel to the y-axis and then up and
you will end up indeed at the end point
of the vector a okay any questions at
this point yes exactly
to add vectors geometrically you just
put the head of the first vector and the
tail of the second vector in the same
place and then its head to tail addition
any other questions yes
that's correct if you subtract two
vectors that just means you add the
opposite of the vector so forth if I
wanted to do a minus B I would first go
along a and then along minus B which
would take me somewhere over there
okay so a minus B if you want to go from
here to here okay so well hopefully
you've kind of seen that stuff either
you know before in your lives or at
least yesterday so I'm going to use that
as an excuse to move quickly forward but
so now we're going to learn a few more
operations about vectors and these
operations will be useful to us when we
start trying to do a bit of geometry so
of course you've all done some geometry
but we're going to see that geometry can
be done using vectors and actually in
many ways it's the right language for
that and in particular when we learn
about functions we really will want to
use vectors more than maybe you know the
other kind of geometry that you've seen
before and of course it's just a
language in a way I mean we are just
reformulating things that you have seen
you already know since childhood but
you'll see that the notation somehow
helps to make it maybe more
straightforward
so what is dot product well dot product
is a way of multiplying two vectors to
get a number a scalar and let me start
by giving you a definition in terms of
components so what we do let's say that
we have a vector a with components a 1 a
2 a 3 a vector B with components B 1 B 2
B 3 well
we multiply the first component by the
first component the second by the second
preferred by the third if you have n
components you keep going and you sum
all of these together okay and important
this is a scalar ok you do not get a
vector you get a number I know it sounds
completely obvious from the definition
here but you know in the middle of
action you know when you're going to do
complicated problems it's sometimes easy
to forget so that's the definition what
is it good for why would we ever want to
do that that's kind of a strange
operation so probably to see what it's
good for I should first tell you what it
does geometrically okay so what does it
do geometrically
well what you do when you multiply two
vectors in this way I claim the answer
is equal to the length of a time's the
length of B times the cosine of the
angle between them so I have my vector a
and if I have my vector B and I have
some angle between them I multiply the
length of a time's the length of B times
the cosine of that angle so that looks
like a very artificial operation I mean
why would we want to do that complicated
multiplication well the basic answer is
it tells us at the same time about
lengths and about angles and the extra
bonus thing is that it's very easy to
compute if you have a component C but
formula is actually pretty easy so okay
maybe I should first tell you how do we
get this from that because you know in
math one tries to justify everything to
prove theorems so if you want that's the
theorem that's the first theorem in 1802
so how do we prove that theorem how do
we check that this is indeed correct
using this definition so in my common
language what does this geometric
definition
well the first thing it means you know
before we multiply two vectors let's
start multiplying a vector with itself
that's probably easier so if we multiply
a vector a with itself using this dot
product so by the way I should point out
we put this dot here that's why it's
called the dot product so what this
tells us is we should get the same thing
as multiplying the length of a with
itself so squared times the cosine of
the angle but now the cosine of an angle
of 0 cosine of 0 you all know is 1 ok so
that's going to be length a squared well
does a chance stand a chance of being
true well let's see if we do a dot a
using this formula we will get a 1
squared plus a 2 squared plus a 3
squared that is indeed the square of the
length so check that works ok now what
about two different vectors can we
understand what this is and how it
relates to that so let's say that I have
two different vectors a and B and I want
to try to understand what's going on so
my claim is that we are going to be able
to understand the relation between this
and that in terms of the law of cosines
so the law of cosines is something that
tells you about the length of the third
side in a triangle like this in terms of
these two sides and the angle here
okay so the law of cosines which
hopefully you have seen before says that
so let me give a name to this side let's
call this side C and as a vector C C is
a minus B it's minus B plus a so it's
getting a bit little here so the law of
cosines says that the length of the
third side in this triangle is equal to
length a squared plus length B squared
well if I start here that would be
pitagoras but I don't have a right angle
so I have a third term which is twice a
length a length B cosine theta okay as
if I want to see in this formula some
time ya know I hear some years I hear
some nose well it's a fact about I mean
you probably haven't seen it with
vectors but it's a fact about the side
lengths in the Triangle and well I'm not
sure that I well let's say if you
haven't seen it before then this is
going to be a proof of the law of
cosines if you believe this otherwise
it's the other way around
so let's try to see how this relates to
what I'm saying about the dot product so
I've been saying that length C squared
that's the same thing as C dot C okay
that we have checked now see that C well
C is a minus B so it's a minus B dot
product a minus B what do we want to do
in a situation like that well we want to
expand this into a sum of four terms are
we allowed to do that well you know we
have this dot product it's a mysterious
new operation we don't really know well
the answer is yes we can do it you can
check from this definition that it
behaves in the usual way in terms of
expanding factoring and so on so I can
write that as a dot a minus a dot B
minus B dot ay plus B dot B so a dot a
is length a squared let me jump ahead to
the last term B dot B is length d
squared and then these two terms will
have the same you can check from the
definition that they dot B or B dot a
are the same thing so there's no hidden
trick here this is really minus twice a
dot B so now let's compare these two
formulas well you see that this term is
I mean this is the only difference
between these two formulas for the
length of C so if you believe in the law
of cosines then it tells you that yes
this is a proof that a dot B equals
length a length D cosine theta
or vice versa if you've never seen the
law of cosines but you're willing to
you're willing to believe this then this
is the proof of the law of cosines okay
so the law of cosines of this
equivalent to each other okay any
questions yes so in the second one there
isn't a cosine theta because I'm just
expanding a dot product okay so I'm just
you know writing C equals a minus B and
then I'm expanding this algebraically
and when I get to an answer that has an
a dot B so then if I wanted to express
that without a dot product then I would
have to introduce a cosine and I would
get the same as well okay so yeah if you
want the next step to record up a law of
cosines would be to plug in this formula
for a dot B and then you would have a
cosine okay let's keep going
okay so what is this good for now that
we have a definition we should figure
out what we can do with it so what are
the applications of that product
well we'll discover new applications of
that product throughout the entire
semester but let me tell you at least
about those that are readily visible so
one is to compute lengths and angles
especially angles so let's do an example
let's say that for example I have in
space I have a point P which is at one
zero zero I have a point Q which is at
zero one zero so it's at distance one
here one here may have a Third Point R
at zero zero two so it's at height 2 and
let's say that I'm curious and I'm
wondering what is the angle so here I
have a triangle in space connecting P Q
and R and I'm wondering what is this
angle here okay so of course one
solution is to build a model and then
you know go and measure the angle but we
can do better than that we can just find
the angle using dot product so how would
we do that well so if we look at this
formula we see so let's say that we want
to find the angle here well let's look
at the formula for P Q dot PR well we
said it should be length PQ times length
PR times the cosine of the angle okay
now what do we know and what do we not
know well certainly at this point we
don't know the cosine of the angle
that's what we would like to find
but the length certainly we can compute
we know how to find these lengths and
this dot product we know how to compute
because we have an easy formula here
okay so we can compute everything else
and then find theta so actually what we
will do is we will find theta in this
way we'll take the dot product of PQ
with PR and then we'll divide by the
length
okay so let's see so we say it cosine
theta is equal dot PR over length P Q
length PR so let's try to figure out
what is vector PQ well to go from P to Q
I should go - one unit along the
x-direction plus one unit along the
y-direction and I'm not moving in the Z
direction so to go from P to Q I have to
move by minus one one zero to go from P
to R I go minus 1 along the x axis and
plus 2 along the z axis so PR I claim is
this ok then the length of these vectors
well we take minus 1 square plus 1
square plus 0 squared square root and
then same thing with the other one
ok so the denominator will become well
as a square root of 2 and there's a
square root of 5 what about the
numerator well so remember to do the dot
product we multiply this by this and
that by that led by that and we add
minus 1 times minus 1 makes 1 plus 1
times 0 that's 0 0 times 2 is 0 again so
we will get 1 over square root of 10
ok that's the cosine of the angle and of
course if we want the actual angle when
we have to take a calculator find the
inverse cosine and you'll find that it's
about 70 1.5 degrees actually we'll be
using mostly radians but for today I
mean that's certainly a more speaking in
certain
okay any questions about that no okay so
in particular I should point out one
thing that's really neat about the
answer see I mean we got this number we
don't really know what means exactly
because it mixes together over length
and the angle but one thing is
interesting here it's the sign of the
answer the fact that we got a positive
number so if you think about it the
lengths are always positive so the sign
of the dot product is the same as the
sine of cosine theta so in fact
the sign of a dot B is going to be
positive if the angle is less than 90
degrees so that means geometrically my
two vectors are going more or less in
the same direction they make an acute
angle it's going to be zero if the angle
is exactly 90 degrees okay because
that's when the cosine will be zero and
it will be negative if the angle is more
than 90 degrees so that means they go
about in opposite directions okay so
that's basically one way to think about
what dot product measures it measures
how much the two vectors are going along
each other and that actually leads us to
the next application so let's see I have
a number one there yes so if I had
number one they must have a number two
the second application is to detect
orthogonality it's to figure out when
two things are perpendicular okay so a
finality is just complicated well from
Greek to say things are perpendicular so
let's just take an example let's say I
give you the equation X plus 2y plus 3z
equals 0
ok so that defines a certain number a
certain set of points in space
and what do you think the set of
solutions looks like if I give you this
equation so far I see one two three
answers ok
so I see various competing answers but
yeah I see a lot of people voting for
answer number four
I see also some I don't know and some
other things but the majority vote seems
to be a plane and indeed that's the
correct answer so how do we see that
it's a plane
I should say this is the equation of a
plane so there's many ways to see that
and I'm not going to give you all of
them but here's one way to think about
it so let's think geometrically about
how to express this condition in terms
of vectors so let's say let's take the
origin you know
oh by convention is the point 0 0 0 and
let's take a point P that will satisfy
this equation on it so at coordinates
XYZ so what does this condition here
mean well it means the following thing
so let's take a vector oh please ok so
vector o P of course has components X Y
Z now we can think of this as actually a
dot product between opie and a
mysterious vector at night remain
mysterious for very long namely the
vector 1 2 3 ok so this condition is the
same as opie dot a equals 0 right if I
take the dot product Oh P dot a I get x
times 1 plus y times 2 plus Z times 3
but now what does it mean that the dot
product between opie and a is 0 well it
means that Opie and a are perpendicular
ok
so I have this vector a I'm not going to
bother to draw it realistically let's
say it goes for example this way then a
point P solve this equation exactly when
the vector from o to P is perpendicular
to a and they claim that defines a plane
for example if it helps you to see it
take a vertical vector what does it mean
to be perpendicular to the vertical
vector it means your horizontal it's the
horizontal plane here it's a plane that
passes for the origin and is
perpendicular to this vector
okay so what we get is plane for the
origin perpendicular to s jit and in
general what you should remember is that
two vectors have a dot product equal to
zero if and only if that's equivalent to
cosine of the angle between them is zero
that means the angle is 90 degrees that
means a and B are perpendicular so we
have a very fast way of checking whether
two vectors are perpendicular okay so
one additional application I think we'll
see that actually tomorrow is to find
the components of a vector along a
certain direction so I claim we can use
this intuition I gave about dot product
telling us how much two vectors going
the same direction to actually give a
precise meaning to the notion of
component four vector not just along the
XY or z axis but along any direction in
space so I think I should probably stop
here but I will see you tomorrow at 2:00
here
and we'll learn more about that and
about cost product